They say history repeats itself.
I'm a big believer in this theory,
which is why I try to spend more time on
the show talking about big ideas and
political philosophies rather than day
to day political rumblings.
Most of our political debates and media
coverage has devolved into catchy
soundbites and zingers usually stage
around some sort of publicity stunt
instead of true substantive debate.
Even protesting these days seems to be
more about screaming and hashtagging
then making a coherent argument.
Just think back to the election itself.
Did the candidates in the media spend
more time on the issues or more time on
the circus?
I think the answer is pretty obvious.
Understanding political philosophies
helps to guide us through the endless
noise that comes out of our political
machine.
This is why I've tried to talk about
issues like gay marriage in a context
which shows you can be liberal and for
gay marriage because you want gay people
to be treated equally under the law.
Or you can be libertarian in for gay
marriage because you don't want the
government involved in a contract
between two consenting adults.
If you understand the philosophic
underpinnings of liberalism and
libertarianism,
in this case,
it can bring you to the exact same
conclusion without understanding
political philosophy,
your thoughts on any day to day issue,
we'll be guided more by your feelings.
Then by fax we see plenty of feelings
over facts in our public discourse these
days,
and it's partly why we're so divided as
a nation.
By the way,
that isn't to say that feelings don't
matter at all because we are humans and
of course they do,
but the way we're governed has to be
based on what is empirically true,
not just what makes us feel good.
Beyond just knowing political
philosophies.
Knowing history is an incredibly
important part of having a well rounded
understanding of how the world works.
Think of how many people you talk to who
claim to know everything about what tax
system is right,
or what foreign policy is best next
time.
Ask them something like,
so tell me the reasons that the flat tax
is wrong or remind me of the history of
the Middle East.
During the Ottoman Empire.
Everyone on television seems to have the
need to pretend they know everything
about everything.
These are the very people you have to
watch out for the most.
If history does repeat itself,
I'm not exactly sure what it's repeating
right now and no,
I don't think we're repeating Nazi
Germany even though it's very trendy to
say that these days,
we truly are at a unique crossroads in
American politics,
which is why I can't directly compare it
to any other time.
It's not just that America has two
diametrically opposed political parties
that are caught between the left and the
right.
Now with Donald Trump in the White
House,
we have a presidential wildcard who has
turned political alignments on their
head.
For example.
Democrats are now suddenly suddenly
arguing for states' rights because they
don't like all the federal power trump
has with his series of executive orders.
This political chaos is also pushing
massive amounts of people,
sick of the extremes on both sides into
some sort of a morphis middle.
There doesn't seem to be a political
leader for this new center,
nor anyone in the mainstream talking
about it yet,
but mark my words,
it's here.
The key to this new center is success
will be who sees it first and who turns
it into a political movement.
Whether that means a new party or
reforming one of the two existing major
parties or something else all together.
While that remains to be seen on top of
this new political alignment,
we also have access to information like
never before.
As I talk about all the time,
we all walk around with the world in our
pockets right now.
You can connect with someone across the
globe just as easily as with someone
across the street.
The genius empower of the Internet's
ability to change our physical world
cannot be overstated.
This connectivity has started
revolutions in the Middle East and shine
light on the inner workings of our
government via Wiki leaks,
but at the same time,
so much of the information is not just
noise alone,
but noise intended to deflect,
confused and upset you made by people
who want to profit off you or outright
control you.
Of course,
if our mainstream media had done their
job for the past eight years,
which is to be the guardian of truth in
our society than maybe the importance of
the Internet wouldn't be so vital to our
functioning democracy in 2017
unfortunately,
cable and network news dropped the ball
at almost every corner and here we are.
They cozy to the power instead of
keeping it in check,
they colluded with the people they were
supposed to keep watch over and they
partied with the very politicians that
they were supposed to be reporting on.
Now suddenly the mainstream media is
trying to get its Mojo back by being
hard on trump,
but I would argue that it's basically
too late to do that.
Actually.
It's kind of sad seeing them flail
around knowing that less and less people
are paying attention to them.
Even right now there's talk that they
are going to cancel the White House
correspondence dinner because so many in
the media dislike trump.
Think how actually insane that is when
they like the president,
they can party with them and drank with
them.
Now that they don't,
well the Jig is up.
Maybe we needed them to guard the guy
they liked as much as the guy that they
don't like.
At the same time,
we more and more catered the news to
ourselves.
We don't listen to pundits.
We don't like.
We impugn the motives of anyone we
disagree with and we block friends and
family who dare have different opinions
than us.
All of this is exactly why we need to
know history and philosophy more now
than ever.
We need to understand where we came from
so we can know where we're going.
We need to know why the founding fathers
wrote the constitution the way they did.
We need to understand why they yearn for
freedom and liberty in a way that seems
almost archaic to us now,
but it's possibly the most important
lesson we could learn this year.
With all this in mind,
I can't think of a better guest for this
week as we continue our partnership with
the fine folks over at learn liberty.
Dan Carlin is a radio and TV personality
who hosts two incredibly successful
podcasts,
common sense and hardcore history.
As a self described political Martian,
Dan uses thought experiments to try to
make some sense of the modern world on
his podcast.
Hardcore history.
He hosts long,
well thought out presentations of
historical events set to the backdrop of
how we might view these events through a
current day lens while he is in
technically a historian,
he's proven himself to be incredibly
adept at storytelling history in a way
that offers some modern day answers to
historical events.
If history repeats itself,
then let's make the next repeat a little
more enlightened and perhaps a little
less painful than the last time around.
Okay.
We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week.
And joining me is a TV and radio
journalist host of two hugely successful
podcasts,
common sense and hardcore history,
and a self-described political Martian.
Dan Carlin,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having me on political
Martian.
I love this phrase.
I understand why you use this phrase,
but tell the people who don't know what
a political Martian is.
What is it?
It came from not being able to have a
good easy description when people ask
you your political views.
I'm really jealous of the people that
can throw a word out there.
And everybody goes,
okay,
I get where you're from.
And I didn't have anything like that.
And so I tried to figure out how you,
in a very nice short way,
describe that you're kind of off the
map.
And that was what I came up with.
Just this idea that,
listen,
I'm from Mars as far as you're
concerned.
Uh,
because no word,
I mean,
I would have to sit there and go,
well,
I'm a little bit this.
And then you,
you start to give them sort of a
political recipe,
30% this 20% and just political marsh
and ends up,
people can nod their head and say,
okay,
I get it.
You're off the grid somehow.
And some of it is also that you're
actively trying to,
to figure out things still,
right?
Like we have this thing in America where
everyone seems to believe or want
everyone else to believe that they know
everything.
You don't come from that position.
Well,
and it's a combination of that and
believing that you have,
and this is not,
you know,
uh,
I'm not insulting,
I hope people who have ideologies,
but this idea that you could have a
template that works all the time is
something that just doesn't appeal to me
because I think you have to be able to
pivot based on circumstances.
You have to be able to,
to admit that something's not working.
But if that conflicts with your
ideology,
how do you reconcile those things?
You have to be able to learn based on
what you're actually seeing.
And I felt like there's not a whole lot
of flexibility sometimes in these
ideologies.
Yeah.
What percentage of people do you think
actually understand political ideologies
in general?
That's what I was sort of talking about
at the top of the show,
but it's like,
I feel like people don't really
understand what really is the difference
between a liberal and a progressive or a
libertarian and a conservative of that
stuff.
Like,
do you think most people even that talk
about politics professionally actually
understand sort of the philosophic
underpinnings of this stuff?
Well,
the easy answer to that is no,
but the second answer is partly because
those words have all changed in terms of
meaning.
I mean,
take,
take liberal as a perfect example.
Uh,
I think I'm a liberal.
I think you're a liberal.
I think most people in this country who
favor a democratic form of government
based on freedom and rights and civic
action and all that,
that we're all liberals in the grand
scheme of things.
Um,
you know,
you have to kind of sit down with people
and,
and dive deeply into what they believe
to try to figure out,
you know,
where they stand.
But,
but on the spectrum of governments all
around the world throughout all time
periods,
we're all liberals.
Right?
Right.
So we're just arguing over,
you know,
what percentage of this or that you want
to,
you want to put it into the category.
But so by,
by not knowing what the words really
mean or by conflating what they meet are
changing what they mean.
I think the reason people use
progressive is because liberals been so
changed in terms of its meaning.
I don't think any of these terms,
what does conservative mean?
I mean I'm fiscally conservative.
What does that mean?
It just doesn't mean anything anymore.
That as I,
as I've done this show,
at least in this current incarnation for
last two years,
I realized I use these labels cause
sometimes you need them to frame
conversations and yet the more we use
them,
the more meaningless they become.
Which is a straight,
I guess I'm a political Martian.
Well,
and the thing is is that,
is that if you sit down and try to
figure out when you're talking to
people,
um,
where do you stand on this issue or
where you stand on that issue.
I always feel like we're all a mix and
that if you think you're really up and
down the line,
give me a little time and I'll,
I'll figure out.
I always say we're all radical on
something,
you know,
I'll find some subject where,
if you said that you felt that way about
it and gave no sort of clarifying
remark,
people would be like,
whoa.
I think,
I think that that describes all of us.
I think we feel like we have to,
you know,
I remember learning about totems and
like psychology one oh one and I think
that's what a lot of people do where
they sit there and say,
part of my self image is that I'm a
conservative or that I'm a liberal and
that locks you in to things.
I mean to be able to say that I base my
opinion on my own views and that I don't
have to fit into any particular box,
I find that completely liberating.
I mean,
people will say that you're
inconsistent.
That's what the author,
well,
you're really not going to say you don't
have a consistent philosophy.
I'm not sure why.
I have to have a consistent philosophy.
Why should we treat a political
philosophy like a religion?
That's actually the reverse of how we
should treat it.
And yet they seem to want this purity
test online.
I mean,
I love that line and I think it was,
um,
who was it,
who said it?
I think it may have been,
uh,
keynes who said,
you know,
that somebody accused him of flip
flopping essentially we would call it
flip flopping good.
And he said,
when the facts change,
I change my mind.
What do you do?
You know?
And that's Kinda how I feel.
I mean I'm not going to get locked into,
I know that I tend to be in my own life
certain ways,
but if I'm a fiscal conservative for
example,
which I am,
and you find out that for this
particular cause you need to spend a lot
of money.
If I determine the cause is worth it,
I'm going to spend a lot of money.
Does that mean I'm a flip flopper right.
So I mean in that sense,
I guess I'm more of a pragmatist but,
but even a pragmatist can be utopian
in ways you could say,
okay,
I want to base things on what's likely
to work.
At the same time I want to shoot for
better than we have now.
Does that make you a pragmatic utopia?
Anest I mean,
do those work and,
and once you start to mix those phrases,
do they mean anything anymore?
I'm a liberal conservative.
I'm a,
I'm a conservative liberal.
I'm a pragmatic utopia and this,
what are these ones?
A lot of stuff I like premeditated
spontaneity.
I mean,
you know,
at what point does it,
does it not make any sense anymore?
Yeah.
How frustrating to some of that get for
you as someone that tries to bring some
of these ideas up that you have to talk
about things sort of in a way that
sometimes can be a little,
uh,
you know,
confusing even for you.
What's frustrating and traditional media
because they demanded that I do that,
which is why it was no,
I was always fighting with people,
uh,
in,
in the world that we're in now and new
media.
It's not frustrating at all.
I can be anywhere I want,
which is why I'm a political Martian and
no one says anything.
They're fine with it,
which is,
you know,
to me that's a sign of the changing
maybe a state of things.
Although it also might be a sign that I
don't have a lot of liberal or
conservative listener could be one or
the other.
I have a lot of political martians
listening.
Yeah.
I think it's probably a little bit,
a little bit about,
I suppose,
uh,
tell me a little bit about your time in
the more mainstream media and what led
you to say,
I'm going to go off the range here and
see if I can figure this out on my own,
which you've obviously been very sick.
I never wanted to do though.
I didn't,
I didn't.
Um,
I was,
uh,
working here in town at,
at the ABC station and,
uh,
I was working on the assignment desk and
I thought,
you know,
I was about 23 and I thought I had it
made.
I thought this was really good and these
reporters would come in who were only a
little bit older than I was.
And so what are you doing to get Outta
here?
And I said,
not that I'm loving this,
this is great.
And they said,
oh no,
you'll die here.
You know,
you'll be doing this forever.
Um,
and so to sort of assuage them,
uh,
I sent out tapes to be a reporter and no
one was getting hired.
So I didn't think there was any real
danger.
And then I got hired.
Um,
I became a television reporter and then
as life has it,
you know,
opportunities intervene.
And then someone gave me a talk radio
show job and I was doing three hours a
day,
five days a week.
And that's where I think things really
started to grow and change because,
you know,
um,
and I,
I'm always,
uh,
I always feel bad for the people that
are getting started today because I got
to make all my egregious mistakes and
how all that stuff go out into the
ether.
It'd be gone if I started today,
those would all be some youtube video
all put together and they'd see every
gaf and horrible thing I ever said or
made.
Yeah.
That shouldn't be understated.
Right.
What you're saying right there,
because I think that's a huge thing.
And I mentioned that I had Dennis prager
on a few weeks ago and I said to him,
you know,
now that you're in the digital world,
you come from traditional media and
radio,
but how conscious are you of being
afraid of saying something that can just
be selectively edited or clipped in a
way that's going to make you seem,
like you said,
the reverse thing,
and then just be relentlessly attacked
for that and the fact that you were able
to have the breeding ground before it
was fully on the,
the uh,
the,
uh,
I guess the infinity grid of existing
forever
sweet digital stone,
little stone as as there is
this thing,
those things will be out there now.
Now that I'm,
now that I've got most,
I hope of the egregious mistakes out of
the way.
I liked it.
It's digital stuff.
Yeah.
I mean I liked the idea that it's never
going away,
but it,
but the kids coming up today who have to
make all their mistakes and have it be
forever available.
I'm,
I'm sympathetic.
I'm glad I didn't exist in that air.
I'm glad I was able to get all of my
nonsense out of the way,
um,
before it was forever.
But yeah,
so in terms of my career,
that's how you learn and,
and um,
and,
and then also the political Martian
thing works itself out that way too.
Because in talk radio when I was there
as I think it still is,
it's really a conservative medium and
you know,
you would have a conservative guy then
you'd have me and then you'd have
another conservative guy.
And I was the one who was continually,
I mean I was at odds with the audience
all the time and I was about 26 and the
average age of talk radio was about 35
to 45.
And so,
I mean,
I,
it was,
um,
it was a baptism by fire that looking
back on it now was really good for me at
the time.
It was really hard.
But I mean,
that's how life is for everybody.
I mean,
you,
you know,
as you're working your career out,
you have these ages where you're just
pulling your hair out sometimes and now
you look back on it.
And it's a wonderful learning experience
at the time,
not knowing the future,
you know,
it's uh,
as I think especially for guys in your
twenties when you really are in a place
where you want to,
you know,
uh,
your self image is so wrapped up in how
you and gosh,
it was such a hard time period and now I
look back on it and think though,
if you don't go through that,
you're not where you are now.
And so,
um,
you know,
when you give your kids advice as a
parent,
there's going to be a lot of that I'm
going to throw at them and hope it
sticks.
Of course they are going to have that
digital,
what do you call it?
The digital stone and digital stone
there.
Their stuff's going to all be etched in
digital and they also talk to the hand.
They don't want to hear anything dad has
to say anyway.
So I'm not sure you can teach your kids
a lot sometimes.
I'm curious,
so you're the,
you were the sort of liberal or marsh
and marsh and even around a lot of
conservative radio.
What do you think it is about
conservatives that it's only
conservative that listened to radio?
Basically?
I mean we know that liberal channels,
Air America and any of the progressive
stuff.
Yeah,
I guess some of it exists here or there,
but it pretty much always fails or
nobody listens.
Is there something about conservatives
and talk,
do you think it's a good question.
And first of all,
I always had a libertarian bent,
which allowed me a place where there
could be a meeting of the minds between
the audience.
If you talk about freedom and liberty
and the constitution,
which I do,
um,
there was a place where we could have
some commonalities and then work around
it.
Uh,
in terms of liberal is because I believe
in things like social programs and
things like that.
So there were areas where,
where we could have a little,
a little friendly competition,
but,
but there were meeting of the minds
areas in terms of why,
um,
you know,
rush limbaugh,
he always likes to say that there will
be a wing of the talk radio history
library and he's right and he will own
that.
But by,
but by changing the landscape,
you know,
I can't speak for other mediums.
I can definitely talk about radio.
It's not extremely inventive and they're
not extremely chance takers,
you know they do.
And so when you see something works,
and I think limbaugh actually said this,
he said for years they told me it'd be
like someone else and not to do this.
And then the minute he makes it then
that then they just want you to be like
him.
I think that was partly my problem too
when I would go in there and say,
why do you want me to be like all these
other people?
They would say because that's what
works.
Look at what's working everywhere.
So I think there's this attitude that,
I guess what I'm saying is if a liberal
talk show host made it big somewhere,
then you would see everybody's saying,
well listen,
this is working in Boston.
You should train of it.
So I think there's a tendency to follow
the leader in that business.
And I think he started off the trend
after the fairness doctrine ended.
Then if you go listen to talk radio
before limbo,
it's a completely different animal.
I mean I remember listening to it as a
kid and it's,
it doesn't bear any resemblance to what
we have today.
So once you see that working,
that becomes the template and if you
want to be big,
you need to do it that way.
So that's why I had such a hard time for
12 years in the medium because I wasn't
like that.
Do you remember a guy by the name of Bob
Grant?
You sure big.
I remember being in the car with my mom
when I was 1213 something like that.
My mom hated this guy,
did not ever agree with him on anything.
His callers would call in,
he would just scream at them and then
they'd hang up.
And it was,
it was just chaos.
And I remember thinking at the time,
who could listen to this kind of chaos.
And yet he was one of the biggest guys
are done that to a guy named Joe Pine
who was the original,
and there was a lot of imitators,
but Joe Pine was,
I want to say,
you know,
you go back to like 1970 and pine
actually had a TV show too.
And it was the first one where you would
just,
cause before that it was like the Dick
Cabinets and everybody you know,
and the William f Buckley's and there
were cigarettes and black and white and
high minded and Joe Pine would just say
you're a communist and you yell at him.
And you know what's funny is is that
when these are novelties,
it's interesting,
but when it becomes the norm it,
it,
I mean I was,
I was talking to somebody the other day
and we were talking about what I heard a
right wing talk show hosts say the other
day.
And I know he doesn't believe that,
but he's got to differentiate himself
from the competition.
So for example,
they were talking about a riot.
And Berkeley and it was who could be the
hardest on the rioters.
And this guy said they got to be taken
out by the police,
put in a back room and euthanize like
animals.
And you go,
well,
why would he say that?
Well,
he says that because he's got to
differentiate himself from the
competition.
Who said the toughest thing?
I mean this guy is going to go vacation
at his house in the hamptons after he
said this.
Meanwhile,
he's ginned up the anger level in the
country so much more now.
Now there's not a lot of individual
responsibility because no individual is
responsible for all of that.
But collectively it's creating a
situation where there's no
countervailing forces.
I mean,
if you're ginning up the anger on this
side,
what's reducing the anger on that side?
What,
what's helping us achieve some sort of
status?
And the answer is nothing.
Yeah.
Well,
I think the answer might be maybe if I
could be so bold,
it would be a little bit of people like
us,
people that like us who
are a little out of the system,
right?
We're out of the mainstream system.
But we're trying to find some answers.
So you get the,
the flame thrower saying crazy things
like that.
I was,
you know,
talking about the protesters myself,
but I'm certainly not for euthanizing
them,
but that people like us who actually
tried to explore some of these ideas are
maybe the counter balance now.
So I get some of that exists.
Same people are listening know that.
And that's an inherent problem I guess.
But I think we're getting some of them
right,
because we know this because the cable
news and mainstream news,
their numbers keep going down and
digital stuff keeps rising.
So we must be shifting some of those
people over.
Right?
I could suggest that maybe it's a genre
playing itself out,
you know,
that's the other problem is that in the
death throws me.
Yeah.
And I think what happens is naturally
you take it more and more extreme,
right?
Because when you're not,
it's,
it's a little like a drug situation
where you need more and more to get the
same effect,
but at a certain point you overdose and
die,
right?
No matter how strong you are.
And I think when you're talking about
euthanizing protesters in the back room,
there's not much further you can go.
Right.
And so maybe what happens at that point
is the genre and the medium and the
style plays out and it's cyclical.
I mean,
I think you could say that again,
like,
like cutting off your heroin supply for
a while and going back.
I mean,
it may come back another round,
but I'm not sure what these people can
do to continually gin up the level of
anger so that those people are still
getting something out of the program.
I mean,
I find this in my own political show
where after a while you think,
at least I think it's getting repetitive
now.
What do you do?
I mean,
if you've already said everything that
you think,
and I'm not willing to say stuff,
I don't believe,
I'm not willing to,
to take it to the next level,
to keep the heroin hit,
you know,
affecting you the way you want it to.
Um,
at what point do you say,
okay,
I've said everything I can say.
Um,
you either take this or leave it,
but I'm not going to continue to hammer
this point home.
I don't need to.
I'll do something else.
Yeah.
I'm not sure everyone has that freedom.
And I know that those people are being
told by consultants on these talk
stations more heavier heat,
heat,
heat.
Um,
so what do you do in,
in those moments where you felt,
I've said this already,
this,
I've made this case,
I've talked about this for a couple
months or maybe a couple of years and
you want to shift.
How do you actually,
do you tell your audience or,
hey guys,
oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
we're going.
I've always been very,
we've been very open with them about my
struggles,
but partly is you try to find different
ways to,
to look at the point from different
angles.
I mean,
that's what I think,
you know,
media with,
with radio especially,
they used to say that because people are
getting in and out of their cars,
for example,
all the time.
You can't go any deeper than 15 minutes
because otherwise,
you know,
you can't assume that people are
following you through this whole
broadcast.
I mean,
they used to say they have to know where
you stand on every single issue within
five minutes to turning on the radio.
That's a cartoon character.
It's a cartoon.
So I said to them that that's not going
to happen.
Now on,
on my program and on your program,
you can show shades of gray and nuance
and especially because that's actually
novel now.
Now that might play out the same way
that the right wing stuff is playing
out.
Right?
But
the novelty of being able to say
everything is a little bit more complex
than you make it out to be is great,
but I've done more than 300 comments on
shows and I start running.
I'm not creative enough to continually
come out with new ways to do that,
at least not to my satisfaction.
The audience says they still want to
hear more of this stuff,
but I'm not sure I want to give it to
them.
That to me seems too much like what I
got away from.
Um,
this is the true artists struggle.
I don't know if you think about it in
those terms,
but really this is the struggle of an
artist to create something successful
and then still feel enough inner power
to continue and not pander and make
something new and all that.
It shows you really thought about it
cause it's exactly right and it's
something that I didn't get initially.
I had to,
I had to learn it by slowly but surely.
First of all,
getting used to the idea that anything
you're doing is art is weird because you
can't call yourself an artist.
Artist is something that the,
that the other people have to say.
And first of all,
I don't think that anything that we do
politically is I,
and that's part of the problem because
now the other podcast that I'm doing has
evolved into something that is a little,
a little bit like art anyway.
And it's so satisfying to be able to do
something where you stand back and you
look at it and you go,
I'd like my grandchildren to hear that
because if I die before they meet me,
they'll get a chance to know me through
this.
Whereas the more I listened to the
political stuff,
even my own stuff,
um,
there's,
I don't see any art and it,
and,
and once you've done some painting,
if you will,
the idea of going and doing my pool
cleaning job,
it's just not as,
as not as,
um,
satisfying.
And at a certain point I'm tired of it.
I mean,
I think we live in a country that's a
representative democracy,
which requires us to be engaged.
Um,
but you,
because of what you do are hyper
engaged.
I'm hyper engaged at a certain point.
And this is why I didn't do 12 straight
years of talk radio because you burn
out.
And especially in my case,
and you and I talked about this earlier,
I mean,
I'm a guy who feels like I rubbed the
magic lamp and the genie came out and
said,
you have a wish.
What is it?
I said,
I want a political outsider because
these politicians are killing us.
And he gave me Donald Trump and I
thought,
whoa,
I really should have had a lawyer with
me to decide exactly how I wanted to
phrase that wish.
And but what that does in my particular
case is I'm not sure what to do anymore
because I got what I asked for four,
I've been doing this 24 25 years.
If you had my radio thing,
I never thought I'd get a political
outsider.
Now I have one and look what I got.
So what do I tell my odd against now
where do I go from here?
For the few of us that publicly or in a
similar space,
I feel that very intimately,
exactly what you're talking about.
I've spent a lot of time in the last
year or two talking about what I think
is wrong with the left because I'm a
liberal and I want the left to be
liberal again.
And now we have trump,
which brings this whole other set of
problems.
And,
and people say to me,
well,
you're not attacking him enough.
And it's like,
well,
we now have this x factor in,
everything is kind of upside down right
now.
And it,
I guess it's incumbent on people like us
to pave the way for other people because
they're,
they're waiting.
Right.
Well,
I mean,
let's get to trump for a second because,
because to me,
you had started out with talking about
ideologies.
This is a different thing entirely.
First of all,
I always say if,
if you could have had a crystal ball
during the campaign and you could've
shown who the nominees for various
official positions would have been,
trump doesn't get elected no matter who
you runs against.
Um,
and I don't think he gets elected if
he's running against even Joe Biden who
I consider to be,
you know,
kind of a zero.
I think Biden runs away with it.
Um,
I think he's a manifestation of our
dissatisfaction with the political
system,
which we are.
I mean,
I don't know anybody who satisfied with
it.
Right.
Um,
and at the same time,
it's not necessarily going to take us
away from our problems because our
problems are too much power in the
presidency.
Not Enough attention paid to the
constitution.
And the fact that we've gotten away from
the various things that make America
great,
which is things like the separation of
powers,
checks and balances,
but the tendency of Americans is to
blame things on,
for example,
the last administration or something we,
this is 50 years of trends building on
top of trends.
This is not a new thing.
Um,
and every president in my lifetime has
taken us farther down the road to what
presidential historian slash singer
called the imperial presidency.
Well now it's the hyper imperial
presidency.
We have a congress that reminds you of
the Roman Senate.
Yup.
At the end where,
where,
you know,
if you say,
what is the real skill level that you
possess as a senator,
it's fun raising,
right?
Lawrence Lessig,
the,
the uh,
Harvard law professor had said that,
you know,
he,
he diagrammed how you work your way up
through the political system now.
And the first thing they asked you when
you want to be a small town mayor
somewhere,
but have a little d or a little lower by
your name is how good are you worked
fund raising.
Yeah.
So by the time you actually achieve a
higher office,
what was the number one qualification?
They were looking for the whole way.
Yeah,
but you were a good legislator that none
of those things.
So these people,
I had a grandmother who was this amazing
fundraiser and she would raise funds for
charities.
She would go to these events and you,
that's what these people are good at.
Yeah.
So it should surprise us very little
when you say,
okay,
we need a check and balance here.
And they're not there.
They're only there now.
There'll be there if they're
contributors want them to be there or if
they can make political hay.
But in terms,
I mean you watch,
you watch the Republicans now in
Congress and it's,
if it wasn't so serious,
it's fun to watch because people are
some of the most astute hedgers you've
ever seen in your life,
but they don't know how to hedge.
Now on this one,
they're sitting there at a fork in the
road going,
do I cast my lot with the trump
administration is going to be a big star
in a hero in 10 years?
In which case I turned the right turn at
Albuquerque and it worked out right.
Or is he going to be seen as a disaster
when anyone who was aligned with him is,
you know,
a nightmare.
So do I need to take,
they don't know what to do and all they
want to do is figure out the way where
they're going to turn out the best so
that I get reelected or whatever down
the road.
I mean,
all of these people are so concerned
about a job that they should only do
temporarily anyway,
that it's warped their entire ability to
have anything connected to what we would
call leadership today.
You,
you've hit on so many things that I talk
about all the time on the show about
separation of powers and an imperialist,
right?
And,
and,
and why we should be governed by the
constitution and not just by the whims
of current events and things like that.
So the imperial presidency I think is a
really interesting thing because I've
been on the record for years that when,
when,
uh,
George W.
Bush was doing all the executive
actions,
I was against them when Obama was doing
them,
I was against them.
I'm against them now.
Now we have a guy who's obviously
willing to govern fully by an
authoritarian who's willing to govern by
them.
But it's,
it's like,
it's not only his fault,
it's not his fault for grabbing the
power that has anybody who was going to,
to him,
somebody was going to do it,
somebody who was going.
So is that the best argument for limited
government then that forget what your
politics are on specific issues that
these people that want money and want
reelections and that are okay to be
authoritarian.
The only fight against them is to reign
in the power they have over us.
Let's talk about that for me because
that's another one of those terms.
So,
just like we were talking about at the
beginning of liberal and conservative
molly's things that are hard to define a
real meaning.
What does limit,
who has a limited government in the
world find what country in the world
has?
Well that's a functioning country,
a limited government who has that?
Because the truth is is we have a
country here that has 300 million
people.
We have a budget that is enormous.
We have needs that are incredible.
Um,
how could you have a limited government?
Well limited I would argue limited
meaning that it should just do less.
It should have a little less control
over us,
meaning that it should take less from
us.
So lower taxes as a general thing.
We could probably scale back the
military a little bit.
We could probably scale back some social
services and they might be taken over a
little more by private enterprise.
That sort of thing.
I don't mean that we should dismantle
the government and not,
you know,
have a driver's license on.
The problem is,
is that you end up,
if you take away,
if you go and you started to remove
things,
you would find out,
I think it's a belief.
So cause we don't do this so it's all
theoretical,
right?
But the belief is is that if you took
away this stuff,
you would find out why it appeared in
the first place.
Now does that mean it's going to come
back in a form that's as bloated and
because we all understand that the
government has built in budgetary
increases every year,
which is again you would say part of the
problem.
This is where a zero balance budgeting
and all that stuff comes into play.
The real wake up call for Americans.
Um,
and it's funny because if,
if I could do anything,
if you were to just say,
I'm going to cut the defense budget by
two thirds and I'm going to give every
American a travel budget where they can
go around the world and begin to see how
other countries work.
Because the biggest nightmare for
Americans in terms of upsetting all your
beliefs is to go to some of these other
and be shocked that it works.
I mean go to Scandinavia.
Scandinavian would not work here because
the entire system is dependent upon you
being Scandinavia.
It's basically a homogeneous and I had
a,
I had a scandinavian girlfriend and,
and we,
uh,
we were getting on the freeway here in
Los Angeles and as you know,
getting on the freeway in Los Angeles is
a struggle.
I mean,
you know,
you have,
and she looked at me and she said,
this is what's wrong with America.
She goes in Sweden,
it would be left hand,
would go right here,
would go,
left hand will go.
And I said,
that's what's wrong with you people.
I said,
that's why you can't compete like we can
because we fight for everything.
Right.
I mean even getting on the freeway is a
struggle,
but when you go there,
what's shocking to an American is that
they have a system that would not work
here,
but it works there.
And they don't tell you when you're
growing up.
These things.
I mean,
you have to actually see it.
Now what that means is you come back
here and you say,
okay,
government is not necessarily,
we're kind of taught.
Sometimes the government is necessarily
inefficient and,
and can't work.
And I always say that that's a defeatist
attitude.
Um,
back when the Clinton Gore,
um,
White House was brand new,
they had a program that they called,
had a great name,
great market look at reinventing
government.
And the idea was that this is not
necessarily the way government has to
be,
right?
Could we improve it?
Could we make it better?
What I'm always suggesting is we really
haven't tried,
and remember it's a big bureaucracy.
Even if you decide you want to go in and
change it,
it's hard to change.
I mean,
I think when you're going to find out
with trump is he gonna find out pretty
darn soon that the bureaucracy has a lot
of ability to push back,
right?
So when I talk limited government,
for me it's about dismantling some of
that bureaucracy so that potentially we
could maybe get to some of that Clinton
and Gore stuff.
For me when I look at the system,
the one thing that we could do that
would affect the lives of average
Americans,
the least in terms of cutting big
government is changed the foreign
policy.
Because when you look at discretionary
spending,
and as we all know,
many of the things like Medicare,
that's not discretion,
social security,
those are not discretionary spending.
The military though is,
um,
and remember that if you go actually
look at a 1960 budget for the u s
military and a budget,
now it's totally apples and oranges
because of the way they did deliberately
hidden things.
So the 1960 budget for example,
the veteran's affairs costs are all
built into the defense budget.
Now it's a separate part of the budget.
So when you'll hear somebody say,
well,
we don't spend that much on defense now.
Well deliberately apples and oranges,
like so much of the budget.
Same thing with uh,
with unemployment numbers.
I mean,
you can't compare the,
the ones in the old days to now cause we
exclude people that haven't been looking
for work,
right?
First.
Okay.
So when you look at the amount of money
we spend and you say that's free money,
that's money you could allocate
elsewhere,
right?
So when you talk about cutting
government,
what would happen if you cut the defense
budget in half?
I think we're still the largest military
spending country in the world.
By the way.
I should point out that we have a
department of defense and yet Americans
have not fought on American soil.
My mother is 80 years old.
She was to the last time Americans
fought on American soil.
What does that money buying us?
So when you talk about well-spent funds,
is there a lot of waste and fraud in
Medicare?
You darn right there is,
but through the government pipeline,
people are being helped on the other end
who's being helped by the defense
budget?
Right?
Um,
when I bring this up,
I'm called an isolationist,
which is a term that goes back to the
1940 [inaudible].
It has all sorts of baggage on purpose.
All I want is a government with a
foreign policy like every other
government in the world.
How can that by definition be
isolationists?
How many basis outside of Russia does
Russia have,
which is probably the next most
interventions.
I think you can count them on one hand.
Okay,
we have in excess of 125 maybe he used
to be 180.
Um,
and you pay for that does a taxpayer,
right?
What do you get for that?
We'll,
is this where trump actually made
headway with things?
Because he would say,
well,
why do we have bases in Japan?
She should be enough for forgetting the
moral center that we may not be sure
about it.
But if you're just the average person,
because he basically made the argument
you're making,
why is Japan paying us to protect them?
So he's making the sort of same argument
that you're laying out there,
right?
Maybe not as both thought out but,
but,
but it's a good point.
And the reason he made it though is the
reason that every president you could
think of makes the argument and that is
that the United States public has been
and always is accepted the most extreme
situations of a mind that they don't
want that.
And,
and when you go look at how this started
between 1945 and 1952 is when the
country made a huge change in foreign
policy and we've never looked back.
They knew you could read the,
the Truman administration and the things
that they knew that the people didn't
want this because it's natural.
They say,
why am I spending money for this,
that,
or the other thing.
Um,
that's why George W.
Bush ran for a more humble foreign
policy.
That's why President Woodrow Wilson and
Franklin Roosevelt both won elections
before they took us into world.
War is on promises to keep you out of
world wars.
There's no precedent that runs for the
United States top job and says,
if you elect me,
we're going to be in more foreign
countries.
It doesn't happen because the electorate
doesn't want that.
And yet that's what we get.
So what,
what does that say then?
Cause if you think about it,
when Obama ran the first time,
one of the reasons he beat Hillary in
the primary was because he was harder on
getting out of Iraq immediately.
That was one of the reasons he was able
to get through the primary to beat her.
Yet at the same time,
he,
I think he's the only president we've
ever had that his entire eight years we
were at war,
we've been in Afghanistan for this
entire ears were still there.
We don't even know.
I mean,
I don't think anyone has any clue why
we're there anymore.
I think you need you to find war because
I was going to say,
I don't think we've not been at war
since 1947 probably since the Truman
doctrine.
Uh,
but it depends on what you mean.
I mean,
is it war if your funding war somewhere
else or is it only wore if your people
are actually fighting and dying?
Because we've been funding war,
you know,
and,
and understand there's a whole
rationale.
It's called military that,
um,
and you can go back and read the
documents at the time.
They're very open about it.
You know,
we have the Great Depression and they
tried all kinds of things to get us out
of that.
We were still in it.
When the gin up 1942 the second world
war started and you go look at the
production numbers and economic numbers
and the graph is almost straight up,
right?
So then in 1943 when it's clear that the
war will be over in a couple of years
and attorney it,
it's like an arm wrestling match and
it's,
it's too far ago,
they start thinking,
okay,
well what happens when we turn off the
spigot?
Right?
Because I had a,
a great uncle who had a small little
rubber plant in,
in Orange County before the war,
when the war started,
the government gave him a huge amount of
money to buy up all the land.
You know,
we need all the,
you know,
all of it,
right?
And then after the war,
they simply said,
do whatever you want with it.
So he sold it and made a fortune just on
selling the land.
But that's the Spigot,
right?
That's the tech.
So there was this feeling that we could
go right back to the great depression if
you didn't keep the spigot on right.
The,
this unnatural amount of cash coming
from taxpayers to military to build
stuff that we might not even need,
but it keeps jobs going.
That's the thing.
If I told you that we could get out of
all these countries in the world would
be fine.
You might say,
that sounds great,
but if I said yes,
but we could also lose 250,000
jobs to people in the defense,
it then when you'd have to say it right,
is it,
but then one must ask,
are these real jobs or these jobs where
you know,
Dave Rubin's tax dollars basically
transferred to a guy who works in the
defense.
I mean,
and is that really capitalism?
You know we,
we,
we go after the socialist countries for
being socialist.
How different is it?
Military keynesianism is a kind of a
socialist,
right?
We're just transferring it in a
different and then when we don't want
the stuff,
this is where,
you know,
it's a bit of a shell game because if we
were really concerned with defense,
you would not give your best equipment
to other people.
Right?
You would not say this is our new m one
Abrams tank and we have it,
but then when you give it to other
people,
what does that mean?
That means they have the same stuff you
do,
which means you've got to go build
better stuff so it becomes a make work
program if you will.
So how much of it is just that that
maybe this thing has grown so big?
I'm talking about budgets and military
and all that.
That t reigning it back in would almost
be impossible short of something
completely radical.
Like I would probably be four,
I'd have to think it out a little bit
further and sit down with some economist
on it.
I would probably be for like a 20% cut
across the entire board for the
government just to just cut every
department back 20% mostly because of
the bloat and the bureaucracy because I
think you could easily get 20% out of
almost everything.
But do you think it's possible that
we've maybe gotten too big,
that somehow turning it back could have
repercussions that we can't even
imagine?
Well,
first of all,
start with when you have a corrupt
political system,
take for example the question of tanks.
We just brought up tanks.
Well,
there's a famous story happened on all
six months,
a year ago where it was a bit of a
scandal because the government doesn't
want any more time.
Military did not want any more tanks.
We have lots of them,
but they build tanks.
It important districts that have
senators who then go and argue that,
you know,
you would decimate my local economy if
we weren't building.
So they're building more tanks than the
military says they want because we have
to keep the work.
See the military also smart,
they locate a,
and I love the u s military by the way,
I'm a military history guy,
but,
but they locate the various important
facilities in places where there are
powerful politicians and what happened?
So you have a real reason.
I mean if you talk about cutting
defense,
you're going to have,
for example,
congressmen down in southern California
who have marine bases that depend on
that money,
that feed families that go into the
local economies.
But again,
do you have a Defense Department for
that?
Is that what you,
and and if you got rid of that,
does that mean you will suffer or does
that mean,
you know,
the,
the true believers in capitalism would
say,
okay,
you will reallocate all that,
right?
If you believe that,
and you know,
I'm more of a pragmatist,
it's an ideology,
but,
but those funds will be relocated to
more productive measures will be form of
creative destruction,
if you will.
Um,
I think that's,
that's a,
a more logical question.
Like if you talk about cutting the
defense budget for example,
by 20%.
The problem with that is you haven't cut
the mission.
If your job is to be the global
policeman of the world,
we're not spending enough now.
So you have to match the funding.
Well,
I would argue that's a problem too,
you guys,
I think you have to match the funding
to the mission,
right?
If our job is to defend the United
States of America,
we are wildly spending too much money.
Right?
Okay.
So,
so here's the thing that never gets
debated.
And then,
you know,
it's like the dog that didn't bark and
Sherlock Holmes,
the subject we never debate is allowing
the American people a voice in the
foreign policy.
Because if the American people are
allowed to decide the foreign policy,
we don't have this foreign policy and
everybody knows it.
That's why we don't have a voice in
that.
So that's why we have,
and,
and it's the one thing,
you know,
do you want to say one thing about
president trump?
He's probably kept more campaign
promises that any president I can think
of whether you want those promises are
not,
but the one he's pivoting on is the
foreign policy promise.
So the former policy problem is
basically people thought he was going to
be more of an isolationist and now don't
use that term.
That's a slur.
You're playing right into it.
Well that he's,
that he was not,
he didn't run on war,
let's put it that way.
He said we're wasting,
a lot of mine are more like other
countries for empowerment.
Right.
Which I guess in the American or hyper
intervention,
right.
So the American Lens,
it comes out as if you're in isolation.
It's,
but just take care of the hyper
interventionists country anymore.
But you suspect that he's actually
shifting on that.
The powers,
I don't think he's doing it because he
lied.
I think you get in there and you don't,
the inertia that,
that,
that gets on you.
I mean,
for example,
the Russian thing is fun to watch.
I mean,
because there's no reason for us to be
at odds with Russia.
And they'll say,
completely agree.
Okay,
what,
what we're going to depend,
these leaders now have to be nice.
He's a bad guy.
I don't think he's a good guy.
But that doesn't mean you get into a
nuclear war
over some miscalculation.
I mean,
listen,
you have international competitors,
but that's light.
And if your job is as our military,
um,
you know,
we have,
uh,
you,
I need to explain this.
We have a policy and they updated all
the time,
a giant sort of global policy on,
on,
on our plans for the next 10 years,
20 years.
And our main goal these policies say,
is to have no international military
competitors.
None.
If that's your foreign policy goals,
you are leading to confrontation.
I mean,
that ends in confrontation and it
requires an enormous amount of spending
because our old goal used to be to be
able to fight two wars on opposite sides
of the planet at the same time.
Who else has a cost?
So the argument,
I read Charles Krauthammer who I dislike
intensely,
um,
the other day and he said,
what makes America great is global
leadership.
In other words,
I guess we weren't great before 1945
but,
but when you think like that,
then the only,
it's not freedom.
It's not liberty,
it's not the constitution,
it's that we are the policemen of the
world and we're the big dog.
And once we lose that,
we're no longer great.
How the heck did we ever survive up
until the second world war?
All right,
so this strikes me as a good segue to
history.
Can you talk about history?
Carlin?
Not,
um,
not,
not with qualifications,
but just as a fan.
So you're technically,
you're not a historian.
I know you're up front about that,
but you're hardcore history.
You do an incredible job of basically
storytelling history with a little
present day context.
Do you see that as sort of the best way
to get people to understand history?
It started off as a show for fans,
which is what I am.
I have a history degree,
but it's a simple ba and,
and we used to do these shows where I
would just,
I assumed that the audience understood
the story and so we were just talking
about the weird things in the story.
I mean I think the first show we ever
did was 15 or 20 minutes and of course
the last one I just did was six hours
and so you can see I never would have
done it if I'd known it was going to be
six hours long or multipart episodes,
but then people would write us and it
wasn't the audience.
I thought it was going to pay attention.
They would say I liked those twists or
what we call Lou twilight zone musings
and they said like those,
but I don't know the background.
Can you give me more background in is as
you well know,
and I always say Seinfeld wasn't
Seinfeld for the first 10 episodes.
Every show has to sort of evolve into
what it's going to be and we started
evolving towards giving a little bit
more information,
then a little bit more information.
Then we had to find out how a non
academically qualified person can
transmit this story in a way where you
could reasonably think you could trust
it and I,
I came up with something we call in shop
anyway,
audio footnotes,
which is okay.
Carlin says something.
Then I back it up with something that a
historian says and then we point out
which has turned out to be one of the
most fun things of the program for
listeners that historians don't agree
because listeners always assumed some of
them anyway,
that there was a history and that that's
how it was to find out that history is a
little bit more like from 500 years from
now,
somebody having an msnbc or Fox News
version of that that turned on a lot of
them.
And so the show evolved
into what it is now,
which part of what it does is show you
how we call it historiography in the
history,
but how history is put together and how
they sort of,
and how it can change over time.
And,
and so what was the original question,
Dave?
Well,
I'll shift.
I should be,
I think he got,
I think it basically got it there,
but I'll shift to this,
which is how I started at the top of the
show that I am a firm believer that
history repeats itself,
which is why what I think you're doing
is so irrelevant.
Is there something historical that we
can look to for our politics right now
and go,
yeah,
it was Kinda like that.
Or are we,
is trump really thrown in such a
wildcard here that there's nothing we
can look and go?
It's kind of close to that.
I've always had,
I don't think his,
you know,
the Mark Twain,
I think it was mark Twain who said
history doesn't repeat itself,
but it sometimes rhymes.
Um,
it's,
it's not that,
it's not that history is so cyclical.
It's that there's a constant element in
it and it's us,
right?
It's human beings.
What did Shakespeare say?
You know,
all the world's a stage and all the,
uh,
all the people,
merely players,
the tapestries change.
But if you could pull people out of the
past,
other than the fact that they're going
to seem like different cultures because
they were raised in completely different
environments,
there's still people,
right?
If you measured them with,
with sensory equipment,
they're going to,
they're going to score the same.
And so that's why it seems similar.
So when you look back,
for example,
at the fall of the Roman republic,
you have two things that are similar.
One human being,
so with the same passions and desires
and foibles and all that,
and then you have systems.
So the reason people always look at
Rome,
the Republican,
everybody thinks empire and it's the
public that's similar is because when
you have a government that is formed
because ours was deliberately modeled on
some of those.
Um,
so you have a similar system and then
you throw human beings into it,
you're going to see things that are
similar because there are patterns that
are going to reemerge.
Does that give you any predictive value?
Absolutely not.
Right?
That history doesn't teach you how,
for example,
I love the,
the right wing always tells you that,
you know,
the Hitler and Munich and appeasement
taught you.
You can't do that.
No,
it doesn't.
It taught you what you can do with
Hitler in that situation,
that the variables mess that up.
So history doesn't teach you how to act,
but it can tell you a lot about who we
are.
So it's basically,
it's just humans really.
It's just humans within the time frame
that they happen to humans and systems.
Right?
Human Systems and culture.
Because you can take people even now
from different cultures.
I mean if you took,
if you took people from a completely
different culture right here,
go to central Africa and replace all the
Americans tomorrow and take them to put
them in central Africa to take all of
the central Africans to put them in the
United States and say,
here's your system.
Donald trumps your president and you
have a midterm election in two years
they're gone.
Do you think there's going to be a few
differences in the voting patterns?
And so you have to factor culture
systems and us the equation.
But that's why history is important
because it really teaches you about us
as a species through cultures and
through time.
Yeah.
That,
I mean that's a beautiful way to phrase
it,
that their historical events you have to
know about.
But really what you're learning about is
just sort of the nature of being human.
And that's argued,
but is there a human nature?
But certainly,
I mean,
we have parameters within which most of
us operate and whether the culture
expands those parameters over time,
there's still,
I mean,
love is love,
hate is hate,
sexist sex.
I mean there's certain things that,
I mean we see the similarities in
primates when you look at them now,
so,
so that's what connects you to an
ancient Egyptian where almost nothing
else would,
right?
Yeah,
they're still people.
And when you read,
for example,
the epitaphs that the ancient Romans
wrote on the equivalent of tombstones of
their children who died,
it touches your heart today.
The way you can relate and the only
reason you can relate is because if you
took a Roman baby and put him in a time
machine and brought him now and raised
him as one of us,
he would be indistinguishable and vice
versa.
You would like watching public
executions for entertainment.
If I took you as a child and raised you
back in the Middle Ages.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure we're going to get back
to that too.
I mean,
you've ever seen,
we do know exactly.
We're not that far from it.
You know,
we,
we really are.
And,
and by the way,
there are parts of the world,
Saudi Arabia,
they're beheading people on the streets
and plenty of people watch and cheer and
all that.
Are they that much different than us or
is their system,
and I guess that's what you would argue
the system around them has just led them
to cheering that right.
It's not true.
Yeah.
Cultural systems systems lock you in
like a republic locks you into certain
things.
For example,
in Rome,
the part that just,
you know,
you look at it and you just go,
gosh,
it looks so similar as a campaign.
Contributions and money and favors with
powerful people.
And the ability of the powerful to
influence,
I mean,
the,
the wonderful part of Roman republic
history for me is when you,
when you read about the,
the attempts,
for example,
of the people who were known as the
[inaudible],
the groggy brothers are famous as the,
as the,
you would call them the champions of the
poor today.
Maybe like you would say the Bernie
Sanders types or whatever.
But what I love about reading the Roman
history and Rome is great because you
have so much history that you can
actually look at and study is that the
people at the time would say that's not
what they really believe.
They're just trying to,
it sounds so good.
Were being paid off by the Koch brothers
and so when you read it,
you just go,
that's a systems thing,
right?
Their system looks like our system and
because of that you throw human beings
as they always are into that system.
The culture part is what makes it very
different,
but I mean you can see echoes of who we
still are today.
Is it,
is it a predictive tool?
Not at all.
But you do look at it and you go,
Gosh,
we are interesting animals and I see it
over thousands of years of difference.
Yeah.
I feel this question may come off a
little,
a little too easy or a little too
cliche,
but are there a couple leaders
throughout time that you look at it as
like truly special in their time?
Oh,
this is everything that you've said.
Making sense.
Like accepting that a lot of it's human
nature and the time they live in and the
system they live in and all that.
But were there a couple that somehow,
or even one that just somehow within
that moment
did something truly special?
See Age old question,
right.
How much,
uh,
how much do the leaders push things
versus how much do the trends and forces
of the time period created an opening
that someone fills?
I mean,
trump is the perfect example of a trends
and forces guy.
I mean we have a situation here where a
vacuum was created that someone was
going to step into and he walked into
it.
He didn't push this,
he didn't make this,
he,
he benefited from it and he took
advantage of it.
He's the beneficiary of the trends and
forces that,
as we said earlier,
had been 40 or 50 years at least in the
making.
Do you think he didn't push it at all?
I mean,
some of the tactics that he think it
really was.
Yeah.
And I think that's why he has to have a,
the advisers he does to try to keep him
in touch with the,
with the current trends as they are in.
And not just the current trends society,
but the current trends amongst the
people who are his supporters.
Right.
He has to ask,
you know,
Bannon,
uh,
how will this play amongst the,
because he doesn't know.
I truly believe if you look at trump,
we always thought trump was either a
centrist democrat or a centrist
Republican.
For him to have the most right wing
administration in anyone's memory is a
bit of a shock.
But he was able to read the lay of the
land and know that there was this crowd
that had been created by the dynamics of
the last 40 or,
and the anger over the situation that,
that he could play to that.
Now he doesn't know intrinsically how to
play to that.
Cause that's not him.
He has to ask,
right?
How will this move,
you know,
react.
So,
so he's a trends and forces guy.
When you look at people that push the
envelope,
you look for people who are wildly
different.
And that doesn't mean good necessarily.
It's just,
I mean,
I'm always impressed with the geniuses.
That doesn't mean that that a guy like
Julius Caesar did not benefit from the
trends and forces of his time because he
did.
But when you read about a guy like
Caesar and you find out that he was able
to sit there in his litter going from
place to place,
dictating three letters at the same
time,
I mean,
and you sit there and go,
well that's a really unusual human
being.
So you put those human beings in certain
situations and you'd say,
okay,
that situation turned out in a way that
it never would have turned out had it
not been for that person.
So there's always an interplay between
the trends and forces and the
individuals who are exploiting them.
It's hard always to separate the line
and say,
okay,
that happened because of that guy or
that woman.
Um,
so when you say historical figures that,
that I,
um,
oh,
I gravitate toward the horrible people
and I don't know why.
Um,
but you look at Alexander the Great's
the one I always look out because to me,
even with all the hyperbole and there's
a ton,
he fascinates me.
He fascinates me because of even the
different views that historians have
over him.
Either he was the enlightened,
a example of a,
of a philosopher king or he was a total
butcher who's been totally mythologized
later on.
And,
and to be able to examine the many
facets.
I mean,
imagine yourself in a situation where
500 or a thousand years from now,
somebody on one hand is trying to
explain you and they're taking all of
your qualities that are the best of you.
And,
and portraying Dave Ruben as that,
but then the other hour,
okay.
But then the other person takes all of
the qualities of the worst of you,
creates a finger or a version of you
that's,
and,
and then multi versions in between that.
That's why I can't,
so when you say the most fascinating
people,
sometimes it's not what they did,
but it's the many versions of them that
you see.
Right.
The mini holograms of Alexander the
Great and,
and dressed up in all the different
forms.
Evil,
terrible guy,
Greg.
You know,
so,
so I'm moved by the figures that are
larger than life and a,
and I enjoy watching how they'd been
mythologized you.
Cause I think we do that today.
I think liberals,
for example,
of mythologized Kennedy,
conservatives in mythologize Reagan,
I've seen the Reagan thing in my
lifetime,
which I considered to be a wonderful
teaching tool for me to then look and
say,
okay,
I've watched how that happens in it.
So now you can see,
okay,
it's obviously happened with all these
other people in history too.
Yeah.
So you think it's funny though with the
Reagan thing,
it's like he was obviously the hero of
the Republicans for the last,
you know,
30 years and the standard bearer of what
a republican deliberately making
conservative,
but then there was this thing in the
last year were Democrats were saying a
lot of Nice things about him because
they wanted to prove that trump was not
him.
So it was like they took the guy that
they hated the most to try to trick,
I guess,
well of
why it was done.
Right.
In other words,
we create a metaphor,
right?
We create,
uh,
an image and weed and listen,
we,
we're singling out Reagan,
but this is the,
this is why I like it.
It's the human thing to do.
We did it with Alexandra to,
um,
you take a person and as soon as they're
gone,
you can easily compress them into a two
dimensional version of themselves.
And then you can use them as a symbol
for what you want them to represent.
Right?
And if you could bring these people back
now and show them in there in the 360
degrees of the human that they really
are,
it'd be,
it'd be amazing to compare them to the
mythology that's been created about
them.
And when you see it done to one person,
it allows you then in your mind's eye to
understand how the process works all
throughout history and not just with
good people,
but sometimes with evil people too.
I mean,
if you go read mine comp,
you know,
the very first history show we did was
asking whether or not Alexander the
Great was a better or worse person than
Hitler.
And the attitude in it was that if the
stories are true,
we'll,
we'll throw the big asterisk if the
stories are true.
Maybe Alexander the Great was killing
all the people he killed because it made
Alexander the Great,
a bigger historical figure.
Whereas when you read mind comp,
Hitler's a twisted human being a product
of his time,
but he thinks he's doing something good,
right?
If you think you're doing something
good,
does that make you a somewhat less evil?
That's a good way to put it.
Then the guy who killed all these people
cause it made him a bigger figure.
So that's a,
that's a heretical thing to say in a
blossom.
This thing to say.
But the point is,
is that do human beings literally go out
to commit evil or sometimes do they go
out to commit good or are these just
byproducts or mistakes or,
or accidents of history.
Right.
And to be clear,
you're not saying Hitler was good,
you're saying never said Hitler was
good.
I'm just going to clean it.
Look,
I'm going to clear that up.
Okay.
You're saying that this twisted thing
that's,
he himself believed it was good.
Yeah.
Here's what we need to do.
We need to get rid of all the Jews cause
it's gonna make things better for
everybody.
Does that make him better than the guy
that gets rid of all the Jews?
Because the more Jews I killed,
the bigger figure I am.
Right.
The whole question is weird.
Right?
But that's what history allows us to
play with and ask ourselves as we
mythologize change and as many decades
pass and we forget either the good
points or the bad points of these
figures,
how do we create a figure that if we
could go back in time and see them as
they really were,
we wouldn't recognize the real figure
anymore.
Kennedy's been mythologized.
I mean,
this is the guy who served three years
on,
often didn't know what I mean other than
the Cuban missile crisis,
which was crazy how good it performed in
that.
If you went back and really elected the
guy today,
how many liberals would be happy with
them?
Just like if you really brought Reagan
back today and put him in front of
conservatives,
he might look like a guy that you
wouldn't vote for it because he wasn't
conservative enough.
Right.
I,
that's the funny thing.
I think for Kennedy it would be,
you'd get some classical liberals and
conservatives voting for him,
but the left,
the left.
That's right.
But,
but,
but the,
the myth is different and the myths
serves purposes.
You're able to put a wonderful bust or
you could put a picture of them at your
convention as look at the wonderful
heroes the Democratic Party's had.
We've had Wilson,
we've had roosevelt,
but would you want any of them today?
Maybe,
maybe not.
So it's almost like we need Greek
mythology in our,
in our system we need here,
or we need marvel superheroes or
something that represent these things
because the people behind them are all
flawed and are screwed up as the rest of
them.
I mean,
this is the thing about Martin Luther
King,
I always try to explain to people is
that that here you've,
you've,
you've created somebody that we can have
a Martin Luther King Day,
which is like the George Washington
chopping the Cherry Tree Down Day,
right?
People forget Martin Luther King.
You go look at the speeches that he was
giving.
He was harsh on the American system,
right?
What did he say?
That he's something the focus evil of
the modern world,
and forget the exact quote,
but it's one of those things that gets
really downplayed when we talk about the
mythology.
You know that they play up the sides
that serve the purposes of us now and
play down the parts where the man was
really revolutionary.
In fact,
my favorite Martin Luther King's
speeches or the stuff we never talk
about anymore because they really edgy
but edgy doesn't serve the purpose of
hero worship and that's how we always
are.
Yeah.
Do you think he evolved that of that
stuff or also as a just a way to go
mainstream to no,
because here's the thing we forget now.
Mainstream is what?
When when king is marching,
for example,
we forget that civil rights was not
something that everybody was going,
yes,
we should have civil rights.
It wasn't that way to simply be asking
to get rid of separate but equal in the
south is radical and they're turning
fire hoses on you and setting dogs on
you,
and a good 40 to 60% of the country is
thinking those are bad people today.
If you showed the same today,
the number
of people that would say,
oh my God,
that's horrible,
would be in the 90 percentile.
But that's because we've moved on.
And in part because of what those people
went through.
In other words,
Martin Luther King is more of a hero now
because the times have changed in part
because of Martin Luther King,
so that he's not seen as the radical.
He was go read the things the FBI said
about him and their minds.
He's a communist.
He,
I mean,
go kill yourself was what they fbi
letter send to you?
Go Kill Yourself.
I mean,
can you even imagine today?
So,
so what happens is when we have these
figures that are radical and
controversial at the time,
if they were ahead of their times,
then they end up looking like much more
banal figures than they really were.
Martin Luther King was revolutionary is
too strong,
but edgy and in a good way,
in my opinion.
But now of course he looks edgy in a way
where we've all gone that route right at
the time.
There are a lot of people that didn't
like his stance and,
and if you think kings edge,
you look at Malcolm X.
Yeah,
for sure.
So any means necessary.
So as someone that talks about the
constitution and the separation of
powers and all that stuff,
and you just mentioned separate,
separate but equal,
right.
Um,
it's incredible to me.
You know,
in our constitution it says all men are
created equal and yet these same people
had slaves.
Eventually we freed the slaves and then
we got to a place where we were allowed
to have separate schools,
but if they were equal,
if they were equal but separate,
then that was okay.
But is the,
is that arc always bending towards
justice?
Because I know it seems like right now
everyone is more at each other's throats
than ever before and angrier and more
divided and all that stuff.
But I would,
I would argue,
and I've had a lot of guests come on and
argue this,
that basically things have gotten a lot
better and we're always going to have
problems for sure.
And that doesn't mean we can always be
better,
but that really things have gotten a
tremendous amount better in large part
because if we were just governed by the
constitution,
it's a pretty great thing.
I require clarification on the word
better.
Better in that it,
we are a more just society and the
United States.
The United States specifically is a
more,
has consistently become a more just
society.
Every decade that has gone by basically.
I am sure we could probably find some
setbacks.
Maybe you could think of a good person
basically.
Yeah,
the Damn Carlin answer,
because wine is going to be different
than anybody else's made me is that I
want you to speak for everybody.
Well,
if I'm here now,
I thought the first 15 minutes we were
talking for everybody,
Dan Carlin.
Here's the way I look at it when I grew
up,
you know,
I think we are,
our expectation levels are set at an
early age and so the era I grew up in
the 1970s I consider to be the high
watermark of,
for example,
things like journalism and as a person
who feels and came up in the
journalistic profession,
that's my background.
I have a high minded idealistic and
maybe even inaccurate historical view of
how I see journalism.
Because if you look at journalism
throughout most of the country's
history,
it starts off in Revolutionary Times as
absolutely,
you know,
I mean they're just yelling awful things
to each other in different papers and
the personal attacks and that's why you
have libel and slander.
People don't
realize that.
No,
no.
It's all,
it used to be a lot of heroin people
don't,
they speak to each other so horribly now
full.
And then you go to the periods,
you look at the 1930s and forties and
it's all corporate stuff,
right?
A lot of the stuff that just fed to you
from a,
you know,
and then you get to the,
the 1960s and even then it's still what
we would call today almost propaganda.
Then you get to the 1970s,
the post Watergate period is this little
teeny era where it was the way I think
it should always be.
And if I'm speaking for everybody,
it's the way it should all be.
Um,
where it was rough.
As a matter of fact,
listener once told me,
and,
and he sent me the speech,
a Katharine Graham who was the editor of
the Washington Post,
had had to give a big speech after
Watergate to all the big wig people and
say,
don't worry,
this isn't going to be a trend.
We're not going to be this,
this,
you know,
expose everybody all the time because it
was so unusual.
But I mean,
if you go look at 60 minutes,
the way 60 minutes used to be,
they used to say,
the worst thing that could happen to you
was to see Mike Wallace of 60 minutes
walking up your driveway.
Right?
Run.
Um,
we don't do that anymore.
And so for me,
if we had the kind of media that we had
in the 1970s,
so much of what I disagree with today
could not stand.
It's like the idea of sunlight being the
antiseptic.
If we talked about it and if we had,
the problem with media fragmentation is
that we're not all seeing the same
things.
Um,
now is that good or bad?
It's uh,
it's a,
it's,
it's something you way,
but in the water cooler discussions in
the 1970s,
we were at least all talking about the
same things.
And you might say the Washington Post
lies like a dog,
but we're still talking about the story
that they wrote and,
and debating it.
Um,
so when you say things are getting
better,
I,
it depends on how you define it.
The iphones are certainly better than
they were in the 1970s,
but I guess we're talking about two
different things.
So I would say I'm,
I was purely talking about just the
rights of the human beings of the
citizens of the United States.
And it depends on if you ask folks from
a cultural minorities in this country,
I think it's better because they've been
progressing at a different pace.
But if you say the rights of Americans
in terms of,
you know the word liberty is a funny
word.
Charles Austin Beard said decades ago,
that all you need do to get a reputation
as a dangerous radical these days is to
go around spouting the sayings of the
founding fathers.
I would say that that the same thing.
We'll get you on a domestic terrorism
list these days,
and yet words like liberty used to be
used in a,
in a real sense.
Now what does liberty mean?
Well,
you could talk to 20 different people
and get 20 different definitions,
but it doesn't mean what it used in the
70s we had this concept,
and it might not jive with the reality
the 1970s but the attitude then was that
they're always going to get better,
right?
Your rights are going to get better.
You're gonna have more rights.
You got all these things and they're not
the 1970s in terms of personal freedom
and all these things.
Not only was it better,
but the concept in the culture was
different.
I would argue that if you grab a 20 year
old today and then talk about some of
the things we used to think when I was
growing up should be part of your rights
and said,
would you like to live in a country like
that?
A decent number of them are not going to
go.
No.
Right.
So I would even say that the concept of
the kinds of country I would like to
see,
Mike had been bred out of my country.
Men because of the changes in the
culture.
Um,
government is much more powerful,
insular,
secretive.
I mean the secrecy had government is a
disaster.
How do we go for that?
We go for it because while we don't have
a press exposing it and talking about
how enrages it is,
but two because the cultural norms put
up with it,
we are much more scared than we were in
the 70s which is part of what,
that's another reason the 70s were so
great because we had just exited an era
where people were as afraid of communism
then is we are a terrorism today and in
the 70s we stopped being,
so it was the beginning of the period
where all of a sudden people would say,
oh my God,
you know the commies are going to come
and you'd say,
no,
they're not.
And yet this,
the taking away of the fear was like
dispelling something and after September
11th then remember it started,
we had World Trade Center bombings in 95
we the omnibus terrorism antiterrorism
maximum 96 I mean this has been a long,
people forget those things,
but nine 11 was a capsize point.
Yeah.
We are too afraid to have the kind of
freedom and liberty that I grew up
expecting.
Not only that we were going to have,
but that every decade it would get
better.
When you say getting better,
that's how we felt in the 70s.
And yet I would say to you,
press freedom is worse.
Personal freedom is worse.
Our,
our conception of what the government
should do is worse.
The secrecy is worse.
So I mean,
it depends on how you define it.
Obviously if you are an African American
in this country,
I think things are better today than
they were.
And then I studied.
Uh,
but,
uh,
so depending on where you're looking at,
what your viewpoint is,
um,
but my argument is from the standards of
the constitution and all that,
the 1970s may have been the high
watermark of American self image of what
these things should be.
So That's interesting.
So that it went from sort of of real
personal liberty,
which we've come along way and pave the
way you want to,
as long as you weren't hurting someone.
So that we've come a nice way.
What we've lost in the course of that is
that we've allowed government to get
bigger and spy on us.
And,
uh,
and at the same time,
watch the press kind of crumble around
us,
but it's our do it and there you got to
look in the mirror.
I,
yeah,
I used to call something the Pinocchio
effect when it comes to the,
remember the Oliver Wendell Holmes had
defined the limits of liberty on the
court and he said,
the right to swing your fist ends with
the other man's nose begins.
And I had asked the question,
what if the other man's nose is
continually growing?
Right?
In other words,
if you say you can live the way you want
until you harm somebody else,
what if you decide things harm you now
that didn't harm you before?
For example,
if you play your music too loud and I
live next door to you and I can't sleep,
you're directly impacting me.
That's a direct imposition on my
freedom.
So you shouldn't be able to play your
music that loud.
If on the other hand,
I smoked cigarettes and my insurance
company is going to have to pay for me
if I get sick,
which is going to raise your rates,
right?
Did I really impact your rights where
people will say,
I can,
I can impact your rights because you're
costing me money.
Okay,
well that's the equivalent of the nose
growing longer.
I call that wallet rights because it's
different than a direct inhibition on
your rights.
It's an indirect one.
Now the problem with that is if you're a
clever,
you can connect point a to point B on
anything.
Yeah.
Why don't you say if it costs you money
in a society is interconnected,
is ours,
then you,
then Oliver Wendell Holmes is whole
proposition goes out the window because
then everybody's actions cost you
something,
right?
So you,
you,
you can't swing your fist at all.
Right?
You'd be out there,
grabbed the cigarettes out of people's
maps,
become the problem.
Once we decided that instead of a direct
challenge to your right to live the way
an indirect challenges and imposition
and becomes cause for limiting you,
then we've destroyed the entire idea
that you have any personal liberty that
you could call your own because
everything you do impacts at least my
wallet somehow.
That's interesting.
So let's just quickly before we wrap up,
go back to the example of the music,
cause I think it's a perfect example of
where we can talk about government
intrusion and personal rights and all
that stuff.
So if my next door neighbor was banging
on the piano all day long,
even if they were playing great,
great classical music,
but it was bothering me,
I would eventually go next door and say,
you know,
if you wouldn't mind maybe from these
hours,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah,
please play impacted my right.
I'm saying this is my right in my own
home to be live here peaceably and,
and not be.
And the older rule,
you wouldn't like it if I did it to you
right now,
would you?
I would use something like that,
but it would be me expressing my
thoughts and then hopefully them hearing
that.
Now what a lot of people would say is,
no,
no.
You,
they would say maybe you would try that,
but if they don't,
well then what's the next step?
Do you go to your local congressmen or
councilman and say,
we need some sort of noise law passed.
Uh,
and then all you're doing really is just
expanding the government to then control
what should be done as an interpersonal
thing.
But sometimes you can't win all of those
interpret what is,
what if the guy just says,
well go fuck yourself.
Sorry Buddy.
That how do you balance liberty and not
an intrusive government?
It's,
this gets back to my views on,
on not educating the American populace
on what their freedoms are and what they
mean.
We don't do enough.
I mean,
liberty's a bad word now.
Yeah.
And yet,
look at your phone,
new documents.
It's,
it's the number,
like the word liberty.
Okay.
But,
but no one even knows what it means.
And Yeah.
So for example,
I always connected it to the golden
rule.
The amount of freedom you're willing to
give your fellow human being in this
country is directly proportional to what
you get.
So you're saying,
God,
that music really disturbs me,
but you know what?
The guy enjoys it.
I'm going to cut him some slack until
8:00
PM and then I'm going to go to him and
say,
hey buddy,
you know what?
After 8:00
PM can we cut it off?
And yeah,
and that's a,
that's,
that's a fantasy way to live because
human beings aren't that way.
But at the same time,
there is a golden rule aspect,
liberty.
And if you get
too restrictive of your fellow man,
you're in effect restricting yourself
right now.
People don't understand this because we
don't do,
you know,
if you go look at the founding
documents,
there are areas,
right and arrows.
Certain things become big in this era.
We talk about terrorism a lot and we,
and we get granular with it and examine
it in,
in that era.
And Liberty was big and all these great
writers,
the John Locke's and all these people we
celebrate today that Thomas Paine's,
they were examining that question from
and their version,
by the way,
what they meant when they said liberty
is different than what even you and I
are talking about today.
They had an 18th century political
concept of what it meant,
but in the 70s,
to get back to the,
what I like to call the high watermark
of our concept of these things,
this idea of your right to live your
life the way you see fit was pretty darn
strong.
And that became restricted due to this
idea that people were going too far.
And in my view,
I have a hard time with going too far in
your rights to live your life,
especially if you're not directly in and
directly not wallet rights directly
impinging on my freedom,
for example.
Um,
we are less tolerant as a species.
I mean,
look at how angry people get at smokers,
for example.
I understand it,
especially if it impacts your health.
At the same time,
there's no sense amongst,
and I don't mean to single out anybody
because we all do this in our own ways,
but to sing them,
to not understand that,
that that impacts you,
they'll say,
well,
I don't smoke so I don't care what I do
to those look,
yes,
but it impacts the general idea about
what you're allowed to do.
They are doing something illegal.
Well and,
and you may not like it.
We all do something that someone doesn't
like.
And the way we've become these way is
very selfish about our rights.
If I do it,
it's important.
If I don't do it and it costs me money
to hell with that.
There's a general concept though that we
should teach in schools about how
liberty is a give and take thing and
that and so then what do you do when
they keep taking?
So going back to this guy,
so now it's eight o'clock.
I've expressed it kindly and nicely to
him.
Eight o'clock rolls by,
he's still slash that's the swing my
nose fifth.
That's when you may need to do have a
noise ordinance.
And that's why I'm not one of those
libertarians who would say you don't
need government.
All these things can be handled between
individuals.
No you can't because some people are
jerks among other things and some,
you know.
So that's what I was trying to get the
line between.
I guess I'm not a libertarian
libertarianism in class.
We can't take care of themselves.
That's the,
I mean,
when you get to libertarianism,
that's my other problem is that I don't
have as much faith as they do that if
you took away the supports,
shall we say,
the people necessarily can take care of
those as I can.
You can.
But,
but not only can,
not everyone take care of them,
great English,
but not only can not everyone take care
of themselves,
but there are people that do absolutely
vital jobs in our society that are not
profit center things.
And you look at the caretakers who take
and they make nothing and you look at
them and you go,
yeah,
but what are you going to do when you
need a caretaker?
Society doesn't allocate resources.
Uh,
and never has.
By the way.
This is,
again,
we're talking about fantasy here in
theoreticals,
but,
but doesn't allocate resources that way.
So when I talk,
I'm a libertarian,
when it comes to civil liberties,
when you talk about how you organize
society,
I always,
I always wonder about what I call the
losers.
And I don't mean that in the terrible,
but there are winners and there are
losers.
And if you have too many losers in your
society,
they will destroy your stuff.
They will make you feel their pain.
I didn't show once,
I called,
well what called one.
What about the losers?
I called the other one,
um,
the,
the revenge of the gangrenous finger.
And I said,
listen,
if you're a human,
if,
if our societies like a human body and
this finger gets disease,
you may say to heck with this finger who
needs it,
it's a small finger and hey,
I got to,
well,
you can get away with that for a while
until it gets bad enough and then it
will make you feel it's pain.
There's a reason the French revolution
happened,
right?
There's a balance and a stacy's that
every society needs and there's a
certain amount it can go before it gets
out of balance.
If you say,
I have an ideological template that says
it's every man for himself and enough
people don't make it,
they'll get rid of your ideology.
Yeah.
And they'll destroy your society.
So would you basically say the classical
liberalism is just sort of a more
realistic version of libertarianism?
That's sort of where I've come around
that I would consider myself a classical
liberal cause I do cause I'm agreeing
with you on this that I,
I see some use for the state.
There are some things that the state has
to do and I want lower taxes,
but I understand that you have to be
taxed.
Everything is a balance.
Yeah.
And the problem is,
is that because conditions change,
you have to continually be rebalancing.
And the likelihood in a system like ours
where your views and my views are not
what the politics,
this is where the corruption comes in.
And I want to use the word corruption
because when we talk about campaign
finance reform or something like that,
it sounds like an issue to be argued.
When you say corruption,
there is no good argument for
corruption.
And what I always say is every
government is corrupt because you can't
help it.
But if you go look at the,
uh,
the US government actually puts out an
index of corruption,
believe it or not.
And,
um,
though at the top countries are the
least corrupt countries and at the
bottom you get to these kleptocracy and
stuff.
So everything's in between.
Um,
even the most clean,
well run.
Governments have some level of
corruption and every government can
function with a certain amount,
right?
But there's a tipping point somewhere on
that scale.
You get to a number where it doesn't
work anymore,
where everyone has to be bribed.
The United States used to rank at a
level much higher than we rank now.
At what point do you get to a place
where it doesn't matter what Dave Ruben
wants her,
Dan Carlin wants,
you don't get what you want.
For example,
all these politicians,
you know,
where the real flaw in our system is,
is a politician can promise anything
they want.
There's nothing that holds them to it.
You have more protection than a
handshake relationship with your
gardener than you do with a person
running for president because they get
into office and change their minds.
The only reason you voted for them is
what they told you.
They,
if they don't do it well,
you can say,
well,
I won't vote for them in four years.
And then in four years you get to a
place where it's them against another
and you hate them both.
Right?
And what are you going,
but that's where the two parties kill us
because they put people,
I mean this and this election is the
best example you'll ever see.
How many people held their nose
regardless of who they voted for and
voted for someone they didn't want
because they really couldn't stand the
other guy even more.
Or the other gal even more.
Um,
who said that they get to pick your
choices and they say,
wow,
you had a whole primary process.
Yes,
but who got to be in the debates?
And who decided that a commission made
up of half Democrats and half
Republicans?
How is it that we let the Democrats and
Republicans decide that the third party
could only get in at 15% nationally?
We let the other two parties we get back
down at the level we let them,
we let them,
and this is um,
you know,
I said it on and people hate when I do
this about looking at the bright side of
some of these things,
but,
but sometimes you don't get the right
reforms in government until somebody
crosses a line.
Was Watergate a good thing for the
country or the bad thing?
Well,
when,
when president Gerald Ford forgave,
pardoned,
uh,
Kennedy Nixon,
he said our long national nightmare is
over.
But we got reforms after that that are
the best reforms we've had in 40 years.
So it was Watergate worth it.
So you say to yourself,
okay,
if you have to fall off the ledge for us
to fix something in this system,
should we fall off the ledge?
Okay.
Only if it gets fixed.
Right.
It's good.
It's about a constitutional crisis.
It's a great thing if afterwards you
solve things,
it's a bad thing if you lose.
And so that's that with Donald Trump.
I can sit there and go,
God,
you know when they talk about a
constitutional crisis,
just hearing the word constitution
sounds like a reform,
right?
But talking about it,
but what if you lose?
So,
so in that sense,
I'm torn between if you had elected
Hillary Clinton,
all those people that are upset with dot
with Donald Trump,
you would have gotten more of the same.
And I would suggest it's 50 to 60 years
of slouching towards
unconstitutionality.
I mean,
to me,
Donald Trump looks like chemotherapy.
He could kill us faster or he could be
something that prompts the equivalent of
democratic.
And I don't mean Democratic Party,
I mean it's a Ma Democratic anti bodies.
He reminds us why authoritarianism is
dangerous and what could happen.
There's a lot of people who don't think
about politics at all.
We,
we have lives,
we have things in our own life that we
have to focus on.
I mean,
you want your country to run on
autopilot and you want it to run well on
autopilot.
But in a system of representative
democracy,
if the people don't flex their muscles
long enough,
things get wiggy been 40 or 50 years
since we've gone out there with our feet
and told government,
no,
you can't do this.
And it takes,
you know,
they talk about a women's protest with
millions of people and that's great,
but that doesn't work.
It has to be protest.
Yeah,
you have to maintain it and then they
listen.
But um,
you could lose and if we lose then you
have to have a plan b country.
Well,
speaking of Pan Be,
I think we're going to have to do this
again to get to some of plan b stuff
because I always say it's a good
interview,
but I don't have to look down once and I
didn't.
And I let you talk David,
like give me any time at all.
Anybody space nicely.
And you took a bit.
This was really a pleasure.
I mean this is what it's all about.
This is what I've tried to bring to my
audience is let's really figure some of
this stuff out.
Let's not pretend we,
we know things that we don't know,
and let's figure out how we're supposed
to be governed and how to look at the
past so we can figure out the future.
So this is,
this is exactly what I like to do.
So thank you for coming in.
You're going to stick around and do a
little rapid fire for our patron people.
And for more on Dan,
check out common sense and hardcore
history at Dan Carlin Daca.